何か質問等あるならばね
はい はい マイクロフォンありますから来ます
旅 旅の途中でですね 死ぬ時ですね
死ぬ時ですか 息を引き取らざるを得ない
普通の人間は でも途中では死ぬわけですけども
そういう人に対して そのブッダが何か語りかけた言葉とかですか
日本だとよく臨終の時に近くのお坊さんを呼んできて
引導を渡すって言いますけども
テーラワーダっていうか
ブッダの教えで 旅の途中でですね
息を引き取る者に対して
何かブッダが囁くというか
説法するような 何かお経みたいなものがあるんでしょうか
あればありがたいんですけど
人間っていうのはバラバラだから
あってもどうしましょうかと
例えば一番最近の例なんですけど
事務局長で頑張っている佐藤鉄郎さんのおばあ様がもうかなり前からもね
癌で末期状態で家で治療していたんですね
それでもうみんな知ってる
もうそろそろそろそろと
それでもう危篤状態になったり
また意識に戻ったり 色々もうもうかなり2
3ヶ月間も もう佐藤さんのお母さんがものすごく看病して
くたくたに疲れていて頑張ってましたけど
佐藤さんはもうどっしり仏教のことを勉強してやってるでしょ
ものすごい理解能力もあるし
知っているし しかし 孫である佐藤さんには
自分のおばあさんに対しては何もできんですよ
だから その方の人生が別な人生だから聞いてくれるかどうか
それでも佐藤さん頑張って色々慈悲の瞑想あれこれやと教えたったんだと
まあうんとうなずきながら聞いていたんですが
分かったか分からなかった
やっぱり分からないんだということを聞きましたけど
亡くなられましたけど
だからそこまでで 孫がもう日本で仏教を広げることにはものすごい手伝って
すごい貢献しているのに
あとさんも本当おばあさんのことすごくなんか愛情で考えているし
しかし できる場合もできない場合もありますね
だから あれはありがたい話で
人間が言っても怒られる
怒る場合もありますね
かえって地獄に落ちる場合
その場合は それっていうのはね
もう輪廻の無知の悲しみなんですよ
だからテーラワーダではこんなのは 1 日でできませんよと
もう終わりやと思ったところで
全てじゃあ真理発見するぞということ 1 日でできません
だからこの智慧の世界だから
子供頃からこそこそこそこそでもいいんだからやってみなさいよと
失敗しても構いませんよと
もういろいろ勉強しても失敗
勉強しても失敗 勉強しても失敗
その人は死ぬ 旅途中で死ぬ瞬間になったら
やっぱりもう一回頑張ってやろうという気分にはなるんですよ
その場合は 語る言葉はいくらでもあります
だから やっぱり日々仏教を学んで
真理と倫理 両方学んで
間違いながらでも生きてみてほしいんですね
戒律を守ろうと もうそっちを破れても
やっぱりそれでも守ってやるぞ
守ってやるぞとかね この失敗しながらでも
もうブッダに説かれた道を歩んだ方がいいんですね
この完璧に完成入れてこんな余計なこと
これはできるわけでもないしね
人間はどうせもうどうしようもないだらしないんだから
もう間違いばっかりなんですよ
しかし 仏教 ブッダに生えた人が幸福にはなること確かなんです
だから いい加減で中途半端ででもやった人であっても
最後になってくるとしっかりもう心は締まってくるんです
あ もう遊んでいる場合じゃないんだと
もう大変だと その時はお坊さんや誰かにこんなことをでということで心配やと言ったら
もう言う立場はあります
我々何を言うかというと
で あの 1個ずつ捨てることを教えるんですね
体はもうダメですねとかね
もう何やってももう まあそうですね
終わりですね じゃあ捨てましょうと
ということで もう家族もまあもう終わりますからね
で 家族から離れたくないと思っちゃうと悲しいでしょうと
でもどうしてももう行かなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
だったらもう家族に対する愛着捨てましょうと
いうことで離れましょうと
この離れましょうという気分でもう悟りの境地に達するんですね
旅の終わりっていうのはすべて離れることなんですね
輪廻転生に終わりがないんだから
壊れたら最後になっちゃいますから
だから答えは離れること
無執着 最後にそれを教えるんです
それがない その程度に発達していない人にとっては
あなたね 本当によく生きてきましたと
もう悩むことないでしょうにと
ものすごい厳しく言うんです
子供のこともね もうよくやってもう終わっちゃったでしょうにと
それなりに頑張って それなりに財産とかね
まああなたの能力ある範囲で財産もいろいろついて
それで十分でしょうにと
それに何を期待するのかと
やるべきことも結構やりましたから
もう喜んでくださいよというふうに言うんです
で だいたいそれで心は私はもう私なりに頑張りましたと
もう仕事終わったと で
はい 最後ならって気分になるんです
そういうことなんですね
まあだからケースバイケースになります
はい はい マイクロフォン取ってください
関連の話になるんですけど
その臨終の時に まだ意識がある時に
今先生のこの長老めのお話を聞くことは非常にいいことだと私も感じますが
亡くなった方に対してそういう言葉は
伝わるんでしょうか 俗にですね
よく死後硬直している人がいるんですが
そういうその意識に話しかけると死後硬直がなくなるというようなことを聞いたことがあるんですが
亡くなった後の方に対してその言葉は通じるんでしょうか
お願いいたします  ちょっとわからない
死後硬直って死んだら硬くなる
あれはティベット密教でやってますけど
あれ変 おかしい  死んだらみんな硬くなります
その時に何かを言うとそれが柔らかくなるという話があるという
あれは誰か科学者に頼んで実験して結果出さない限り私は認めませんだけど
私も死体は見てますけど
死んだらだいたい 24時間経つと硬くなりますけど
それから国の天気によりますけど
それからまた柔らかくなりますよ
誤解しないでいただきたいんですけど
生きてる人間に先ほどの長老めのお話をするのはもっともなことだと思うんですね
亡くなった方に対しても
その言葉が通じると考えてよろしいんでしょうか
自己満足なんでしょうか
それは自己満足ですね
亡くなった人が今いる生命から来て
自分と直接交信するならば
客観的に喋れますけど
それ以外 こちら勝手にお墓に喋ったっても
それは我々の自己満足で
我々の悲しみも和らげることも大事ですから
なんだかんだ言って自分の悲しみを和らげるのは構いませんよ
しかし それで死者が何か役に立つかというと
そうはならないんですね
今 日本の仏教などお線香をインドに渡すというのはほとんど意味がないということ
それは私はちょっと 前言いましたからね
はいはい 前に回してください
えっと フックが 4つあるというお話だったんですけども
心臓に毛が生えてる人がいいんですけどね
心臓に毛が生えてる人がいいんですけども
すいません ちょっと気持ちの強い人はいいんですけども
気が弱い人 恐怖とかいうのがですね
それが引っかかって それで恐れを抱いてやりたいことができないとか
あるいは道を誤るとか
そういうこともあると思うんですが
恐怖っていうのは 先ほどの 4つでいうと怒りの類に入ると考えていいんですか？ 恐怖は怒りですね
はい だから聞きたいことなんですかね
恐怖  5つ目が恐怖があるんじゃないかなと思ったんですけど
思ったんだ なるほど  それはないんですね
恐怖やら楽しさはただの感情ですから
こちらにシステムに入りません
恐怖で引っかかることになりません
だからこれ引っ掛けなんですね
このフックなんですね
でも例えばテロリストに対して
その本当はいろんな方法があると思うんですよね
でも武力で対抗しようというふうに考えてしまう人たちもいるわけですし
それはやっぱり恐怖心から自分を守ろうという
いろいろですね スリランカも武力で全部潰しちゃったんですけど
恐怖心というよりはね
お前ら何やってるのかというね
いい加減にしろよと 調子でやっちゃったんですね
で アメリカにとってはそれは商売ですから
テロリストがいないとね
困りますから いろいろやっていて
だから恐怖心かどうか分からないんですね
本当にみんなに対してはそんなにも
もっともっとしたたか
もっとしたたかな気持ちがあるということですね
そんなにテロリストが思っているならば
もうとっくに潰してるでしょ
だからなんか我々を馬鹿にしているんじゃないんですかね
まあとにかくそんな世間の話はどうでもいいんだけど
個人個人ですごい恐怖心を持っている
だから輪廻転生するんだっていうことは
で 確実じゃないんです
恐怖心だから何とかしたいと言って
恐怖心のあまりに瞑想して悟りに達することもあります
だからそれは自然に生まれてくる感情だから
仏教はそれを何とか役に立てないのかと
踏み台にできないのかと考えるんです
例えば欲 欲もなんとかして踏み台にできないのかと
したりはするんですね
しかし 本当の問題は このシステムってカーヤですね
カーヤっていうのはボディという英語英訳でしょ
英語でのボディっていうのはシステムという意味でも使えます
仏教も同じで カーヤといえばシステムということで
この 4つのシステムができちゃってやられているんですね
だから恐怖心は引っ掛けにならない
フックにならない 欲もならないんです
異常欲なんです フックになるのは
怒りもならないんだよ
異常怒りなんですね 気をつけてるんです
ありがとうございます
あ すいません あのゴータマブッダがあのブッダになるってことを前に
あのイーパンカーラブッダというあの念想仏というブッダに指名されたんですけども
必ずそのブッダになる人は過去生において指名を受けるのかというのと
それからその次のブッダになるマイトレーヤも誰かから指名を受けたのでしょうか
そこは仏教伝統的な仏教伝統の話ですから
私にはあの何も言えないんですね
否定もできないし 賛成もできないし
伝統はどう書かれているのかといえば
勉強しているんだから説明できます
それはどうかと聞いてもわかりよくわかりません
お釈迦様 経典の中では 6人のブッダのことはよく出ます
なのにお釈迦様 私はウパッシブッダからこう言われましたってあまり言わないんでしょうし
よく知っていただけの話はするんですね
それもご自分の過去を見られる能力で見ていってるんだと
だったらその時は私は菩薩として認定を受けましたとか言ってもいいのに言ってないしね
仏伝ではずいぶん明確にきめ細かく
これでこれでこう受けた
こう受けたとか書いてます
それはもう面白いことはもう大乗仏教でもその話がありまして
我々仏教でもその話がありまして
一般的にはみんな認めている世界になっちゃっているんですね
そういう話になってくると
何千億でも差がないんですね
なんだこれと思いますけど
教えに対していろんなごちゃごちゃ間違ったことを言ってますけどね
よくわからないんですよ
それで弥勒菩薩にしたっても
認定を受けなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうするとお釈迦様から認定を受けなくちゃいけないんですよ
あんまり出てこないんですね
経典の中でお釈迦様が誰かの比丘に会って
君はもう将来弥勒仏になりますよ
弥勒仏陀のエピソードは
経典の中で一箇所しか出てないんです
膨大な経典の中でも それもお釈迦様に会って認定を受けた話じゃなくて
将来は弥勒という人が如来になりますよというぐらいの話ですね
それとですね その まあ例えば仮に一人の人が将来ブッダになるとしても
その そのブッダに志願する人っていうのもものすごい数がいると思うんですけど
そのだから菩薩っていうものが
その大乗と小乗の小乗というか
テーラワーダの菩薩の概念が
要するにその指名するために
こうパラミタというか
善行為をしてその待ってるっていうことだと
なんかこう 私の考えではなんか似てるっていうか
誰が？誰に？ その善行為をして
そのブッダに指名されるまでこう輪廻をして
その待ってるっていうことが
その阿羅漢になる道とはちょっと違う別の道だとすると
その似ているような気がするんですけど
それは  似ているって何で似ているんですか？と聞きたい
その大乗の菩薩とテーラワーダの菩薩がやってることは実際の中身は
菩薩という観念は当然似てますよ
それはもともとこちらから大乗に行って
もうもう拡大して壊れただけなんです
だからもともとテーラワーダにあった言葉なんです
菩薩っていうのは我々日常茶飯事で使っている言葉で
今も人間の中でものすごい大胆にすごいいいことをしたら
もうあの人は本当に菩薩でしょうという風に褒めるためにも使う単語なんです
しかし よっぽどの人間でなきゃ言わないんですけど
そこはもう大乗の方に行って
どんどんどんどん増えて
広げて広げて広げて 何も味気がなくなっちゃったんですね
だからこれは塩一粒の例えがあるんですよ
塩 1かけらっていうのはすごくしょっぱいですよ
あの料理に入れたっても結構効き目があるんですよ
それがもうもう 1万リッターの水の中に入れて溶けちゃ
何の役にも立ちません
ただのメスなんです だから一切所乗が菩薩やと言ってるんだから
もう話がそれで終わり
で 言葉はもう似ています
で 定義は間違ってます
大乗は 元々大乗にも歴史ありますからね
もともと菩薩でしたけど
正真正命の 後でヒンドゥー教になってからは
神が変身して菩薩になるんですね
そうするとブッダより菩薩の立場が上になっちゃうんです
これあべこべになるんですね
犬が尾っぽ振るべきでしたところで
尾っぽが犬を振ることになっちゃうんです
だから 例えば観音とかね
この延鎮菩薩たち見るでしょうね
で 如来より偉いんですね
如来がわざわざと観音になるんだから
わざわざ苦労するんですね
で でも観音の思考は幾つありますよ
一つは観音가もうその気になったらすぐ悟れますけど
永久に悟らないで 一切所乗を救うために輪廻にいる観音もいて
如来が変身して観音になっている
この立教真言とかね そういう世界の観音の概念また違った
例えばティベット仏教も同じなんですね
観音っていうのは如来そのものなんですね
そういう風にいろいろ変化して変化して歴史的にいくんですよ
だから当てにならないんですよ
次何言うかわからないんだからね
それは好き勝手に変える概念というのは概念じゃないんです
だから もし私の話もさっさと広げちゃうと変えますよ
みんなこの考え方は 狂暴だから
こちらの批判は いろいろ訂正する羽目になっちゃう
そうするとどこまであんた方訂正するのかとにこともなりますよ
で おっしゃる通りに菩薩概念っていうのは似ています
あの初期時代の菩薩の概念は
菩薩はパーラミターを修行する
悟る目的で頑張っている人であると
ボーディっていうのは悟り
サッタっていうのはそこを祈願しているという意味で
生命って意味なんですけど
注釈書では祈願しているもの
悟りを祈願しているもの
だから味覚なん 味覚者なんですね
だからどこででも菩薩はあり得る
菩薩を拝むっていうことはちょっと違うんですね
それはちょっと成り立たないんです
菩薩は忙しい もう仕事中
人に「はいはい 君 はいはいはい」と会って祝福したりしてね
そんなもう立て場がないんだ
一生懸命パーラミタ完成しなくちゃいかんだからね
当然人を助けることはパーラミタですから
布施パーラミタでもパンニャー何でも
生命を助ける 助けて助けて助ける能力を向上するっていう話ですよ
しかし 例えば 例えば観音様の話が本当ならね
みんなもうとっくに解脱しているでしょうに
だってじっともう観音だから
じっと見ているんですね
聞いてるんですね 人々の悩み苦しみを
実際は一人の悩み苦しみも何のこともやってないでしょうに
で まぁ菩薩はやっぱり人を助けますよ
そこであのブッダになろうと思っている人々を教えるっていうことは
それはないんです 日本仏教は論理的に
教理学的にみんな菩薩であると
みんなブッダになるんだと
みんなに仏性あるやと
は言ってるんだけど 誰一人もそう思ってないんですね
誰一人我はブッダであるという風に調子に乗らないんです
自分の宗教はそう言ってるのに
その気持ちとこれはもう観念とごまかしできないんです
気持ち的にはスケールすごく小さいんです
みんな 日本の大乗のお坊さんたちでも
もう自我を張って皆に嫌われるだけで
そうでないと普通にすごい謙虚で生活しているんです
身を引き締めて 小さくて
ドーンとお前らはなんだ
はい こっちいらっしゃいと調子を取らないんです
私ほどは取らないんです
私は清浄仏教ですけど
えらいスケールが大きいんです
全然人々を相手にもしないんですね
そんな態度を取らないでしょ
だからこの現実的にはないんです
ブッダになろうと思う人々は
助けてやろうではないかとチッチャと出て行って
そこは勇気もないんです
だから ある日私はこの方々に言ったんです
本当の大丈夫って誰かと思いますかと
中を見たらあなた方でしょうと
症状も気持ち悪いほど症状なのは
我々はどうですかと  2500年やってきましたよと
なんで私たちから一般人が離れないのかと
こちら出て行けと追い出したっても
泣きながらまた来るんですから
そんなこと言わないで
もうもう謝ってくるんです
なぜかというと こちらからずっと人々のために頑張ってるんです
だから 最強の人々がちょっとでも調子に乗ったらこちら追い出すんです
大乗仏教のそれは逆なんですね
ピカピカピカピカとすごく機嫌取るんです
だからいつでも助けてあげる側が強いんです
助けてもらう側はもう条件飲み込まなくちゃいけないんです
だからテーラワーダ世界ではなんでその状態でしょうかと
世界ですごく我々は支配している
悪いこと悪口言われますけど
どうしようもないんです
カトリック教会のは自分の信者さんは支配管理できないんだけど
私たちにはもうものすごい簡単にできますからね
で そこはこの支配欲でも権力欲で何でもないんです
ただ慈しみでも悪いことはしてはあかんからね
仏教だから人の何とかして人に道を案内しなきゃ
もう仕事してないですね
仕事してるだけ だからそこはもうもし客観的なバイアスなくない人が仏教を研究すれば
もう明らかにテーラワーダ仏教が大乗仏教と言わざるを得ないんです
何としてでも助けてあげるんだから
何か何か何でもする そこまで勇気があるのかって
私はこの人格的な問題ですよ
菩薩になりたいっていうのは
その人の人格であって
悟りに悟りに達したいっていうのも
人間っていうのはスケールの大小があるんですよ
ブッダになろうと思う菩薩のスケールがあんまりにも大きすぎなんです
だからあんまりにも大胆なスケールで物事を考えて行動するんだから
じゃあ瞑想して悟り じゃあだったらブッダになってやるぞという風になっちゃうんで
それなら なんで それだったらたくさんの人々にも助けます
助けられますから だから菩薩になりたいと思っている人々は
もう最近までスリランカでも何人かがね
もう何年何年もいて 昔もいましたし
現代でも何人かがいましたけど
やっぱりスケールが違いますよ
もう国を揺らぐぐらいもういろんなことやっちゃいます
菩薩の祈願しているんだから
もう普通の人間ですけど
結局は 普通の人間だけど
あの威力はもうどうにもかなわないんですね
それで私も私はすごい
もうもうものすごい 何でももう何て言いますか
もう絶対の目で何でも見る性格だから
もうやっぱり何も言えなくなっちゃいますね
あの力感じると 小さくはないんです
そこですっごいひどい力
人格としてパワーを持ってる人々っていうのはすっごい少ないです
だから当然ブッダの世界の教えですから
菩薩たちはいますよ けど
ナメじゃないんだよ ああいう人々は
亡くなられても その人々の影響は続くんです
しかし 経典の中でね そんな認定してもらうとか
あれやこれやとか記録してはないんです
で 菩薩の修行はどんなものか
パーラミタはどんなものかと書いているものは全部経典の後で書かれた仏典でしょうし
読んでみると何か気持ち悪くて
なんだこんなアホなことをやってもとかね
いう気分になっちゃうんですね
やっぱり書いた人々の考えでしょうね
あんまりそれほどかっこいいと思わないです
これも私の率直な感想ですからね
まぁどうったことはないんですけどね
私も感動させることはできなかったんですね
この菩薩の修行のなんだらかんだらと読んでもね
ああ そうかというということで
はい まあ時間が結構です
まあそれで終了しましょうか
まあ質問はもうまだございますか
四つの引っかかりがあるということで
四番目のヴィナンサチャーリーなんとかなるんですけど
これあの 要するに気分の問題なんですか？気持ちの問題なんですか？ 違うでしょうに
見解が正しいと思うって
見解が正しいっていう風に思ってるっていう心の問題なんですか？ だから見解はそれに正しいんですよ
それが問題なの だって言ったでしょ
これは黄色いバラと思える
でしょ しかし これは必ずしも紫色のなんだら花という証拠はある？ありません
でしょ？あなたに紫色に見える
それだけの話でしょうに
これはどう見ても紫色の花と思ってしまうんですよ
もしかすると光がここら辺に流れる場合はね
ちょっと湾曲しちゃってね
あなたにはその波動しか目に入らなかった可能性もあるし
わかりませんよ まあ例えばこの光が変わえたらね
これは赤くなったら 青くなったら全く違う色になるでしょ
この蛍光灯でこう見えるんであって
今はもう太陽がないんだけど
太陽のところに持っていったらどんな色か分かりませんよ
で なぜか私も別な色を見えますけどね
だから私は推測できます
しますよ あの太陽のあたりではこういう風に見える
この蛍光でこういう風に見えるとか
スポットライトだったら別に見えるとかね
私の見解はそれなんです
私は だからワンギーさんに聞いたら
これは紫ですかと 聞いたらそういうわけなんです
なぜならば 私は勝手に紫色の花という自信がなかったんです
私のは紫じゃないんです
はい すいません 圧倒されました
それで あの 例えばご自分の子供は可愛いと思っちゃうでしょ
しょうがないでしょ  憎たらしかったりもしますけど
その時もしょうがないでしょ
ただの人間やと思える？ただの世の中にあるどこら辺でもいるただの子供やと
自分の子供だけなんか違いますね
見え方違います  そんなもんですよ
だからもう我々は常に己の見解が正しいということに引っかかっているんです
わかります ありがとうございます
はい はい では終了いたします
では 回向の文で終了いたします
[回向の文] ありがとうございます